cinquante cinq mille voyageurs sont
concernés depuis ce matin aucun train ne
circule sur la ligne e du transilien
cette ligne reliant la verrière à la
défense est fermé en raison d'un
incendie survenu dimanche à 4 heures du
matin à la station sèvres ville d'avray
un poste de relais donc un poste qui
commande la circulation ce lundi seule
la moitié des trains au départ de
versailles rive droite circulent la
ligne e -u quant à elle est totalement
condamné pour deux à trois semaines
aucun bus supplémentaire ne sera mise en
service une solution insuffisante face
au volume d'usagé trop important la sncf
encourage les voyageurs à s'orienter
vers la ligne c du rer et le tramway t2
vers la défense
pour l'heure aucune mesure
d'indemnisation n'est envisagée